le gulfstream va-t-il disparaître les
scientifiques sont inquiets ce courant
marin qui adoucit la façade océanique de
l'europe affaiblit c'est une conséquence
de plus du réchauffement de la planète
en fondant la banquise est en train de
modifier un équilibre séculaire nicolas
chateauneuf rémy poissonnier
parvis sous la neige l'image est rare et
spectaculaire
elle pourrait pourtant devenir la règle
en hiver d'ici quelques dizaines
d'années avec une france croulant sous
les flocons comme c'est le cas chaque
année de l'autre côté de l'atlantique au
canada ou aux états unis notre pays est
situé au même latitude mais il bénéficie
comme toute l'europe d'un 'régime de
faveur' celui du golf stream un puissant
courant d'eau chaude qui remonte de
l'équateur ballet de manière saisonnière
la moitié sud des côtes américaines et
traverse l'atlantique jusqu'à nos
rivages cet immense radiateur océanique
permet à l'europe de bénéficier de
températures plus clémentes refroidi il
replonge jusqu'à 5000 mètres de
profondeur pour repartir vers l'équateur
le problème c'est que ce golf stream
donne des signes d'essoufflement
grâce à des balises posées au milieu de
l'océan des scientifiques britanniques
ont noté que son baby avait chuté de 30%
ces 50 dernières années one est apte
mais lorsque les estimations sont
arrivés et ont montré que la circulation
des courants étaient si différentes j'ai
été très surpris c'est tout à fait
nouveau pour certains scientifiques cet
affaiblissement du gulf stream est liée
au réchauffement climatique avec des
eaux plus chaudes à nos latitudes est
moins salée à cause de la fonte des
glaces plus au nord son fonctionnement
seraient perturbés tout comme son
influence sur notre climat
s'il y avait eu un déplacement de ce vol
fruits ou des grandes structures de la
circulation océanique les régions
affectées par les dépressions pourrait
être différente et donc les pluies par
exemple entre le nord et le sud de la
france qu'on va avoir des
caractéristiques différentes par rapport
à ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui certains
modèles prédisent qu'un ralentissement
du gulf stream pourrait dans un premier
temps compensé une partie du
réchauffement climatique en europe mais
au delà d'une centaine d'années le
refroidissement pourrait l'emporter et
plonger l'europe dans un nouvel âge de
glace